Bertrand quanta sort un nouveau single
avec son groupe aujourd'hui soit 20 ans
après la mort de Marie trintignon cette
annonce a créé une nouvelle vague
d'indignation faut-il interdire ces
prochains concerts faut-il interdire
faut-il interdire de de de de de faire
de continuer à chanter de sortir des
titres qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
avant d'en débattre regardez ce rap
regardez en 2003 sur fond de violence
conjugale Bertrand conta est condamné
pour le meurtre de sa compagne
conséquence proba des coups qu'elle
aurait reçu au cours d'une dispute avec
son compagnon libre depuis 2007 le
chanteur avait alors effectué plusieurs
retours sur scène malgré de nombreuses
contestations et aujourd'hui 4 ans après
son absence l'homme vient de sortir un
nouveau
[Musique]
morceau un morceau qui a surpris de
nombreux français et qui a grandement
fait réagir alors plus de 20 ans après
avoir tué Marie trintigan le chanteur
Bertrand quanttin sort un nouveau titre
aujourd'hui faut-il interdire ses
prochains
concerts je voudrais des noms d'abord
parce que c'est c'est c'est curieux de
voir des noms euh donc je voudrais un
nom euh moi tu peux pas l'interdire il a
été en prison il a purgé sa peine voilà
maintenant il est c'est légal il va
faire un concert le concert est légal si
des gens veulent aller payer leur place
pour aller voir un mec qui a tué sa
compagne si lui il est content de
chanter et de se faire applaudir si lui
est content de danser de chanter de
crier s'il se regarde dans une glace
après en se disant ça me va je suis
heureux J'ai tué ma compagne mais
regarde je fais un kiff on mange quoi
après regardez je chante le la salle se
lève
c'est son problème à lui et sa
conscience interdire interdire le
concert on peut pas interdire le concert
donc c'est pour ça que je met non on
peut pas interdire le concert mais ce
mec là moi il me dégoûte et j'aurais pas
j'aurais préféré qu'il fasse profil bas
qu'il fasse autre chose maintenant c'est
fini pour moi c'est migel Mohed moi je
pense que que ce mec est une merde par
contre je suis contre la censure si les
gens ont envie d'aller le voir qu'ils
aillent le voir et ben je partage tout
ce qu'à dire r Oui non je pense
qu'effectivement on ne peut pas
l'interdire de chanter on peut pas
interdire aux gens d'aller le voir je
pense qu'il y a aussi des gens qui
apprécié qui écoutit avant Bertrand
quanta qui écoutit avant Noir Désir
avant qu'il commette cette horreur et je
pense que il y a un peu d'hypocrisie
là-dedans on a tendance à conceller les
gens et à dire que on aime plus ce
qu'ils font parce qu'ils ont commis une
horreur moi il y a des artistes qui ont
dit ou ou commis des choses horribles
bah j'aime encore leur musique j'aime
encore écouter leur musique et après ça
nous regarde pas nous en tant que
spectateur si parce qu'en fait on espèce
de faire culpab on essaie de faire
culpabiliser les gens d'aller voir
Bertran quanta d'aller écouter sa
musique après tout s'il est sorti de
prison il a le droit de faire de la
musique il a le droit de se produire et
pour moi son œuvre n'a rien à voir avec
ce qu'il a fait même si c'est évidemment
horrible moi par exemple pour titre
personnel puisque tu parlais des gens
qui adorent Bertrand qui adorit la
musique moi Noir Désir je l'ai écouté je
suis allé faire quasiment tous ces
concerts j'étais immense fan aujourd'hui
je ne me verrai absolument pas dans une
salle de spectacle pour applaudir parce
que j'applaudis un homme qui a tué une
femme donc moi je pense que
effectivement il ne faut pas interdire
parce que c'est à chacun de décider s'il
a s'il se sent capable d'aller applaudir
un homme qui a tué moi je ne me sens pas
capable d'aller applaud José Mustapha
oui non mais moi le public j'ai l'in
criminé aussi parce que pour aller voir
ce mec faut sériusement dérang par
contre non on censure pas un artiste si
les G on envie d'aller le voir c'est un
problème de conscience ça les regarde et
lui est-ce qu'il peut encore se regarder
dans une glace je ne le crois pas
galdine fait vous avez raison dans tout
ce que vous dites mais moi effectivement
je trouve que c'est indesscent et c'est
obsène et j'ai effectivement beaucoup de
mal à faire la part des choses alors
déjà tu disais que les gens ont le droit
de de l'écouter oui on a le droit de
l'écouter en plus il gagnent beaucoup
d'argent grâce à ses chansons d'avant
donc tant mieux il peut vivre encore du
fait qu'il a été chanteur de Noir Désir
et compositeur et interprète donc ça
c'est tout va bien pour lui
financièrement et c'est m mais moi
d'abord je pense à la maman de de Marie
trtigon qui a toujours voilà qui est qui
ne s'est jamais remis de la de
l'assassinat de sa fille des coups de sa
fille du fait qu'elle a été assassinée
mais vraiment avec le visage tuméfié par
un type qui l'a mais voilà il a pris que
8 ans de prison au final il en a fait
que troisd que aujourd'hui c'est ça le
signal quand même on dit aux gens vous
donc vous tapez votre votre
votre la massacr elle meurt coma machin
tout ça il prend 8 ans il il n'en fait
que trois il sort et aujourd'hui il
monte sur scène franchement c'est
catastrophique je trouve que c'est un
signal catastrophique alors oui
évidemment il y a toujours la loi
l'esprit de la loi mais je trouve que
c'est indescent ceux qui vont la voir le
voir en concert je trouve que c'est
aussi obsène il y a un truc de secte
comme
ça en parles dans ton livre d'ailleurs
de ça des femmes qui sont amoureuses de
gens il y a plein de femmes qui écrivent
à noirir enfin à Bertran qui sont
amoureus de lui qui
TR moi moi il y a une certaine presse
qui me choque pardon mais les un ro
quand ils font leur une avec Bertrand
quanttin le glorifiant moi me ch
ch voilà après chacun décide d'acheter
ou pas
le si vousvezz endu 2024 pour être
choqué par la
presser par je parle de la presse oui on
va pas oui moi je trouve que ceux qui
mettent nom c'est le nom de la honte
franchement j'ai honte pour vous parce
que pour
moi pour moi il doit être emmuré dans un
silence public éternellement tu veux je
te dis écoute écoute écoute ce qu'a dit
Raymond écoute ce qu'a dit Raymond pour
une fois écoute un peu ce que disent les
gens excuse-moi Raymond qu'est-ce qu'il
a dit écez il a dit un truc très vrai il
en vérité pour il a peger sa peine bien
sûr moi je suis pas pour qui chante mais
en vrai c'est lui de prendre la décision
il a raison exactement ça lui pas être
indécent mais toi Gill Verdez encore une
fois
excuseiste il il nous parle tous les
soirs de la loi les squats ils ont le
droit de rester parce que c'est la loi
mais lui la loi ou normalement tu aurais
dû mettre non lui qui a pas de face
c'est lui qui a pas de face lui
normalement il doit dire lui lui
normalement il doit se dire après ce que
j'ai faiti j'ai plus aucun k dans ma vie
je dois plus je dois plus kiffer en
fa il peut kiffer dans sa vie de tous
les jours avec ses potes ma il va où il
veut mais profil bas moi je trouve très
indécent de monter et de crier de
chanter même pour les femmes qui sont
battues même pour les femmes qui tout le
monde mais je comprends les nom comendom
nom parfait ils ont tout bien dit je TR
not
oui à nous en il vous parle avec
l'émotion exactement en vérité le N nous
on est la loi et eux ils sont dans la
loi en disant ex moi au départ j'étais
oui et quand je les ai écouté je suis
non oui bizarrement mais quand je vais
t'écouter je vaisre encore plus non donc
vas-y il faut l'interdire il faut
l'interdire il faut que les villes
l'interdisent il faut que les gens n'y
aillent pas il faut que les associations
féministes laisse-moi finir il faut que
les gens que les associations féministes
comme elles l'ont fait manifestent il ne
doit plus chanter tu sais quo tu sais
quoi tu sais quoi tu sais quoi voilà une
fois de plus une fois de plus mais
regarde les gens retourne la Pancar tu
es tu es insupportable excuse-moi je
t'adore mais tu es
insupportable l'IND des sens c'est lui
qui l'a tu veux que je te dise moi je
trouve que c'est encore je vais dire si
les gens qui vont le voir et moi je suis
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit Valérie avec
ce qu'on dit avec ce qu' dit Raymond tu
vois je dis Valérie Raymond avec ce
qu'ils ont dit ils ont tellement bien
résumé l'affaire celui qui a pas de face
c'est lui je te le dis donc il faut
arrêter d'envoyer toujours des
associations au feu des associations au
front Gill Verdez c'est encore ta France
de merde excuse-moi je suis désolé Gill
mais il y a pas d'association là c'est
lui et sa conscience le gars il y a pas
une association il y a pas de truc ça
suffit avec ça d'accord il a purgé sa
peine en vrai qu'est-ce que tu veux que
je te dise on l'a dit même même si c'est
et si lui il a pas de face pour aller
rechanter et ben qu'est-ce que tu veux
que dis on dira bah lui ce garslà il a
pas de face voilà c'est tout pour aller
faire le beau sur une scène quand le
toxico il a fait tomber la grand-mère
avec la petite gamine qui voulait
l'enlever tu voulais pas mettre le mec
en prison tu as dit je suis content
parce qu'il va aller que un an
exactement qu là tu veux faire des
manifestations mais c'est ça mais arrête
avec tes associations laiss les
tranquilles les associations arrête avec
ta France des associations arrête un peu
avec ça arrête oui ouais je suis il y a
pas que lui et sa conscience même si
c'est important d'accord mais un
instituteur qui qui est accusé de
pédophilie il fait sa peine après il a
interdiction d'enseigner et ben lui il
il devrait avoir interdiction d'aller se
faire aduler
applaudir public ça tient pas ton argum
bah non mais on peut être un monstre et
un très bon artiste et moi je comprends
ah a plein de preuv moi je pense que
quand on a aimé bertrandanta et quand on
a aimé une musique de bertrandanta ce
n'est pas les actes tant horribles
soit-il qui vont faire nous faire
changer d'avis sur la qualité
de moi j'ai un nom comme toi mais là je
ne te rejoins pas du tout moi par
exemple je m'interdis aujourd'hui
d'écouter le moindre morceau de Noir
Désir oua pardon je ne peux pas me dire
que je suis en train d'écouter de
trouver c'est formidable un type qui a
tué
moi voulez que je vous dise par exemple
moi je trouve que toutes les radios ne
devraient plus diffuser
frtin mais titre personnel on a le droit
de l'écouter et c'est pas parce qu'il a
commis quelque chose qu'on doit
s'interdire faut arrêter de culpabiliser
les gens enfin voilà c'est pas notre
problème s'il a commis des horreurs bah
c'est tant pis pour lui il a été en
prison pour so on a le
droiter les gens éc pas
entaché tu V dire un truc le boulanger
c'est un très mauvais exemple le
boulanger il fait ça s'il a ple sa peine
il vair sa boulangerie les gens achf que
le prof du bélonger c'est pas de se
faire applaudir sur
une g paschet son
mais le librearbitre des gens mais donné
il faut arrêter de faire dans le social
genre on va pas bien sûr que si on va
faire culpabiliser les gens qui écoutent
un meurtrier c'est si en fait il y a un
féminicide tous les 2 jours et demi et
ça pour moi ça banalise tout donc si la
justice a mal fait son travail il a mis
que 3 ans en T autant qu'il fasse bien
après qu'il interdise de se produire an
lui il a fait que 3 ans il a fait que
ANSI elle sa vie elle est finie pour
toujours que c'est plus qu'une horreur
sa vie sa vie elle est finie et lui
continue à kiffer et en plus pour
l'enrichit pour moi c'est nimporteoi une
cot
€ pas c'est mais oui dan mais beaucoup
de choses ont été dites et en fait les
noms c'est un petit peu des oui je suis
désolé on ne peut pas cette personne a
non seulement massacré sa femme n'a pas
prévenu les secours pendant 5 5 he donc
il aurait peut-être pu la sauver à ce
moment-là sa femme qui sa vraie femme
qui l'a soutenu s'est suicidé par ses
comportementors avec tout ce que je vous
dis là d'abord d'abord scandale premier
scandale 3 ans pour tout ça c'est
honteux et alors en plus et en plus on
va s'asseoir et on va applaudir ce
monsieur je suis désolé l'exemple moi je
suis d'accord avec Jean-Michel l'exemple
du boulanger est très bon parce que il
fait du pain on mange du pain à la
limite on sait même pas qui est le
boulanger mais s'asseoir dans une salle
pour applaudir quelqu'un qui a fait ça
il y a des gens qui mettent non
è
nor regarde rappur MHD qui est dans une
affaire de meurtre les gens continuent
d'écouter sa musique moi j'adore sa
musique après il a fait quelque chose
d'horrible peutt voilà Ken antis an j'
jeis pas antisémite arrête de mett g
dans
lacter des G qui font des Dinger c'est
vous qui avez des des mecs vous ad des
mecs qui
sont me
meem jusêes
cont regardezle sur scè quand il a des
détracteurs en face de lui regardez je
chose la plart des gens qui sont là sont
là pour des bonnes raisonsux qui ne sont
pas là pour les bonnes raisons sortir
maintenant ces gens une chose c'est que
il n'y a aucune limite à quel point je
vous
emmerde
cont
diti c'est pas le débat on voir les
résultés non 5 en voyz je pense que vous
avez convaincu les gens Raymond et et
Valérie et comme Jil a mis oui à mon
avis ça aussi voilà ça ça ça fait
basculer les gens ah